react query a react library that
simplifies the way we fetch cache and
synchronize data from a server react
itself has no opinions about how you
fetch data from the front end the most
basic approach is to use the browser
fetch api when a component first mounts
and use effect then manage the response
with use state that works but becomes
increasingly difficult when requirements
like caching retries and deduping come
into play react query not only
simplifies your data fetching code but
also handles these complex requirements
out of the box for example you might
want to refetch data when the user
leaves and then comes back to the same
window fetch on windowfocus handles that
for you if you're building an infinite
scroll feature the use infinite query
hook will make your life much easier or
if you're writing data to the server you
can make changes appear instantly in the
ui with optimistic updates and you can
debug all your data fetching logic with
its integrated dev tools they've thought
of pretty much everything and it's so
good at what it does that it might even
eliminate your need for a global state
management solution to get started
install it with npm then instantiate the
query client and provide it somewhere in
your component tree now every child
component will be able to fetch data
like a pro also add the react query
devtools here to debug and development
now define a function anywhere you'd
like to fetch data from your server and
the component that consumes that data
add the use query hook it takes a key
that allows react query to manage this
data efficiently then the data fetching
function as the second argument it will
make the request then return the data
and also the status of the request if
it's loading we show a loading screen if
the request fails it will actually retry
the request three times and if it still
fails at that point the status will
change to error now if it was a success
we can render out the data in the ui and
that's a lot of functionality with not a
lot of code but you might be wondering
what this key is all about well now
let's imagine that we want to update
this data on the server to handle that
we can bring in the use mutation hook
when data is written to the server we
can hook into it with the on success
function and automatically invalidate
the query we already made based on its
key this tells react query to invalidate
and refetch the original request and we
can even tap into the state of this
process by referencing is fetching from
use query to keep tabs on the loading
state now if you want to run multiple
queries in the same component you can
easily do that and it will automatically
run them in parallel to ensure optimal
performance but sometimes one query
might depend on data from another like
all the cars owned by a user that's also
made easy with the enabled option like i
said before they've thought of
everything this has been react query in
100 seconds if you want to see more
content like this enroll in my full
react course on fireship io that breaks
down a ton of react concepts in 100
seconds or less thanks for watching and
i will see you in the next one